The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: All right today we
begin a topic dear to my heart.
It's a problem that's
still pretty open,
but I've worked on a lot.
Dynamic optimality.
Central question here is, is
there one binary search tree
that's at least as good as
all other binary search trees?
Is there one binary search
tree to rule them all?
It's kind of a
fundamental question.
Goes back to the '80s.
In particular splay trees, which
you have probably seen before.
We'll review them briefly here.
And there's a lot of
technology built up,
which we'll talk about this
lecture and next lecture,
about how to tackle
this problem.
It's still active
area of research.
So before I get to-- well
the central question here is,
is there one best
binary search tree?
It's a natural question because
we use binary search trees
all the time.
Already in this class,
probably every lecture,
we've used a binary
search tree for something.
And we all know how to do order
log in balanced binary search
trees.
And the question becomes,
is this the best you can do?
To make this more formal
of a problem, well, yeah.
I want to define binary search
tree as a model of computation.
OK we've talked about
pointer machine model.
Binary search tree model is
a more restricted version
of pointer machine.
So it's less than
pointer machine.
Just so it's clear what
the name of this game is,
we require the data to be
stored in a binary search
tree as it's keys.
And then we allow
basic operations.
Let me make sure I
get the right list.
You can follow
pointers, and we're
going to assume our BST
has left triad pointers,
right triad pointers,
and parent pointers.
You can do each of
these in constant time.
And then the interesting one,
interesting thing you can do,
is rotate a node and its parent.
So sure you've seen
rotations before.
If this is my node
x, and I do rotate
x, it's going to be my
definition of rotation,
x moves to the root.
It's in this case because x
is to the right of it's parent
it remains now to the
right of it's, what
now becomes it's child.
These sub-trees come
along for the ride.
This preserves the binary
search tree property.
And you could get
back by rotating y.
OK by this definition
of rotate we
don't need to
distinguish between left
and right rotations.
We always name the child and
it's parent is well defined.
That's who we rotate with.
So it's just flipping this edge.
So these are the operations
you can do, and in this model
really the only thing
you can do is a search.
Suppose I want to
search for a key.
The model is to do a search I
start at the root of the tree,
of the binary search tree.
I can do these walks.
I could do rotations.
And I must visit--
if I'm going to search for x,
must visit the node with key
equal to x.
And we're going to assume
throughout these lectures
that searches are
always successful.
You're only searching for
keys that are in the tree.
Doesn't make that
much of a difference
if you're searching for keys
that are not in the tree.
Think of it as searching for the
predecessor or the successor.
Not a big deal.
And so for
simplicity, we're just
going to assume
successful searches.
We're also going to assume
no insertions and deletions
in this model, because they just
make problem a little messier.
Some papers have considered
insertions and deletions,
and to the large extent
things just work.
So, we're going to
focus on searches.
Searches is interesting
enough for this problem.
Suppose I have n items.
Now the model is clear.
I store them in a
binary search tree.
These are the only
things I'm allowed to do.
Could I imagine beating log n?
Well, no in the worst case.
This is best possible
in the worst case.
Why?
Because your tree has
to have depth at least
log n if you're going to store
n things, and if it's binary.
So your adversary could
always be, could always just
look at your tree
and say, Oh I'm
going to pick anybody who's
a log in depth or lower,
and if you're going
to start at the root
and walk left and
right to get there,
you're going to have
to pay log n time
every single, every
single operation.
So actually there's a lot
of sequences, in fact,
most sequences.
You take an average sequence,
this will be the case.
But we'll see formal ways
to prove that next class.
But, easy adversary
argument tells you
you need to go down,
log n in the worst case.
But, that's the worst case.
The name of the game
in dynamic optimality
is to consider every case
separately, and do as
well as you can all the time.
In general, the answer
to this question is that,
is log n best possible?
Depends on the access sequence.
Depends on what
you're searching for.
So, let's say we're, to
make things a little clean,
let's assume that the
key is we're storing are
the numbers,
integers, one up to n.
So in particular
there's n of them.
And really we just
care about their order,
so I'm going to relabel
them to be one up to n.
And say we search for x 1
first, then we search for x 2,
and so on, up to x m.
So, these indices
are time, basically.
Over time, and you can
plot this if you like.
Here is time.
Here is space.
So at the first time
unit we search at x 1,
then some other place,
then some other place.
We can have repeats, whatever.
OK.
Some search sequences
are going to be slow,
they're going to require
log n time per access.
In particular, if I always,
if the adversary chooses
x i to be the deepest node
in the tree repeatedly.
But some search sequences
are going to be fast.
Any suggestions, if you don't
have the notes in front of you,
of access sequences that we
can do in less than log n
time per operation.
Let's A constant.
There's a lot of possible
answers, I think.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: N divided by two.
PROFESSOR: N divided by two.
What do you mean.
AUDIENCE: Like it's
going to be [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, if you're
searching for the median
in a perfectly balanced tree?
Yeah, that's true.
So if you're always searching
for the root of the tree,
in particular, that's
going to be good.
That's hard to, that
depends on the tree though.
I'd like a particular
access sequence
that I can always serve
as well, with some tree.
AUDIENCE: n order walk.
PROFESSOR: n order walk.
Yeah, good.
So this has a name.
Sequential access property.
If you want to access the
elements in order, so one
through n, this should only
cost constant amortized.
Because for any tree
you can do and in order
walk in linear time.
And so per search, if you're
careful about how you do this,
now this is not totally obvious
in the model that I've set up,
because I said search
always starts at the root.
If you let your search
start where you left off,
then you can definitely do this.
It turns out you can
assume this or not,
it doesn't make a difference.
That's maybe a fun exercise.
But if, you can essentially
reroute the tree
to be wherever you left off.
I'm not going to
prove that here.
OK, but in particular, some
trees have this property.
Some don't.
I mean if you use a red black
tree, and you search for one,
then search for two,
then search for n,
you're not going to
get constant amortized,
because it doesn't
realize this is happening.
But if you're clever, of
course, this can be achieved.
Easy way to see
how to achieve it
is, this is your
binary search tree.
You access one, then
you do a rotation
with the right child of one.
So then you have this
binary search tree,
and then you access two,
and then you do a rotation.
This is basically a
way to make a deck.
View a, use a link, simulate a
linked list in a binary search
tree.
OK, so it definitely can be
done by some binary search tree.
A stronger version of the
sequential access property,
it's a little more interesting,
is dynamic finger property.
This is something that should
hold for every access sequence,
and it gives you a measure
of how expensive an access
sequence is.
So we're doing x
one x two up to x m.
And we say, if we
measure the key distance
between our current access,
x i and the previous access,
x i minus 1.
If that equals k,
then ideally we
should be able to do log
k amortize per operation.
So in the worst
case this is going
to be log n, but if I look
at my space-time diagram
here, if for example, if
I do sequential access,
then this number is always one,
and so I get constant time.
If I do something like this,
where my spatial distance is
not changing too much,
and this is the reason
I numbered the keys like this.
What I really mean is, in
the sorted order of the keys,
how do the ranks differ.
But if I number the
keys one through n,
that's just their
absolute difference.
So anything like
this, dynamic finger
properly tells you
you're doing well.
Dynamic finger property can
be achieved by a binary search
tree, but it's quite difficult
as you might imagine.
Or it's difficult, let's say
not necessarily super hard.
If you don't need to do it in
a binary search tree model,
an easy way to do
it is with what's
called a level linked tree.
So a level link tree
looks like this,
and I add pointers
between adjacent nodes
in the same level.
This is a pointer
machine data structure,
it's not a binary search
tree, because binary search
trees we only allowed to do walk
left, walk right, walk parent,
But it's an easy way
to do dynamic finger.
You start from
somewhere, you basically
walk up to the right level,
move over, walk back down,
and you can do a search for x
i from x i minus one relatively
quickly.
It turns out this can be
stimulated by a binary search
tree, but we won't
go into it here.
Lots of fun puzzles here.
Let's move on to some
more bounds or properties.
So, next property is called
the entropy property,
or entropy bound.
And it says if key k appears
p sub k fraction of the time,
then I'd like to achieve
a bound of entropy p
k log one over p
k per operation.
This is, everything here
today will be amortized.
So, if you haven't seen
entropy, that's the definition.
It's the entropy of
this distribution.
We're thinking of
these as probabilities,
although they're not
really probabilities.
They're, because this is
over a particular sample.
We have this sequence x1 to x
n, There's no randomness here,
but we just measure
what is the fraction,
what is sort of the observed
probability for each of these x
i's.
And then just say,
what is the, what
is the entropy of
that distribution?
In the worst case
it's log n, if say
everybody's equally likely,
everyone's accessed once,
or the same number of times.
But if it's highly
skewed, like if only one
element is accessed, the
entropy will be constant.
If a small number of
elements are accessed,
entropy will be constant.
So this can be
achieved, and in fact,
if you disallow
rotations, so if I change
the model to forbid
rotations, all I get to do
is set up some
binary search tree,
and then I have to walk left,
walk right, walk parent,
from in that binary
search tree to do this.
So if I get to
see the x i's then
I get to build a
binary search tree.
One binary search tree.
This is what's called
the static optimal, when
you're not allowed to change the
tree as you're doing searches.
Entropy is the best
bound you can get.
And roughly speaking, key k
appears at height, or depth,
log one over p k in the
tree, maybe plus one.
And you can show there's always
a tree where every node ends up
at depth log one over p k.
Again, not hard, but
we won't do it here.
OK, a related property,
it's called the working set
property.
Little bit harder to state.
For each search we
do x i, we're going
to see when that's some key,
when was the last time that key
was accessed.
So, in our space-time diagram
we have some access at time i,
we want to look backwards
in time to the last time
that key was accessed.
Say that was, well some other
time j, and in this interval
we want to know, how many
distinct keys were accessed.
So it's at most, i
minus j, but maybe there
were some repeated accesses,
we only count those as one.
So how many different
keys were accessed
during that time interval?
Claim is, we only have
to pay log of that.
So what this means, what this
implies, is in particular,
if you're only accessing say
k different elements at all,
and you ignore all
the other elements,
then you'll only pay
log k per operation.
That's why it's sort
of a working set.
If you're focusing
your attention
on k elements for a
while, you only pay log k.
But in general, for any access
sequence you can compute,
what is the working
set costs, which
is you sum over all
the i's of log t i,
that is your total cost
for the access sequence.
Divide by n, that's
the amortized cost.
OK?
That's another
nice property, not
so obvious is that working
set implies the entropy bound,
so this is a stronger property.
I guess dynamic finger
implies sequential access,
but there's no relation between
working set and dynamic finger.
In fact, they're kind of
transposes of each other.
Working set is
about, if you access
a key that was accessed
recently, then it's fast.
Dynamic finger is
saying, if you access
a key that is close in space
to the previous access,
so here we're looking
at a key and basically
in the very previous
time step we're
looking at how far
away it was vertically,
here we're looking at how
far away it was horizontally.
So they're almost
duals of each other.
Be nice if you could
have one property that
included both dynamic
finger and working set.
I should mention, again
this is not obvious
how to do it with a
binary search tree,
but it can be done.
Leave it at that.
We'll see eventually
some trees that have it.
For now I just
want to cover what
are the conceivable
goals we should aim for.
All right, log n is too easy, so
we need more challenging goals.
So the next property,
it was introduced,
this is we're getting into
more recent territory, 2001,
it's called the
unified property.
Natural name, and it tries
to unify dynamic finger
with working set.
And the rough idea
is, that if you
access a key that
is close in space
to a key that was
accessed recently in time,
then your access should be fast.
So, here's the formal statement.
So here's the unified bound.
Let's draw a picture.
So here we're accessing
x i at time i, sorry j.
Change of notation.
Time j.
We want to evaluate
the cost of x j,
and we're basically
going to look in--
I guess one way to think
of it is this cone.
90 degree cone, where
these are 45 degree angles.
And if there's something--
and look at the first thing
that you hit in that cone.
Is that the right
way to think of it?
Maybe not.
It's like you're growing a box,
this is probably more accurate,
and you find the first key
that you hit in that box.
It's a little more
subtle than that
because we're only
counting distinct keys,
and let's say you find this
key, and this key is good
because it's temporal distance,
this time, is only this big.
It's spatial distance
is only this big.
What we're going to
pay is, log of the sum
of the spatial distance,
and the temporal distance.
And temporal
distance is measured
as the number of distinct keys
accessed in this time interval.
So, as long as there is some
key in the recent past that
is close in space, you take
the min over all such keys,
magically a unified
structure has
to find what is the
most recent close item
and search from there,
and achieve log of that.
There's a plus 2 just to make
sure if these things are zero,
you still get a constant.
Always have to
pay constant time.
OK, so that's a
unified property.
Fairly natural generalization of
dynamic finger and working set.
I mean you could change this
plus to a product or a max,
doesn't make a difference.
Yeah.
Sadly we don't
know whether there
is any binary search tree that
achieves the unified property.
What we know is that
this can be done,
this property can be achieved
by a pointer machine data
structure, which is more
powerful than a binary search
tree.
But we don't know whether
it's possible to achieve
by a binary search tree.
Best bound so far, is
that you can achieve
this bound plus log log n.
So as long as this
never gets too small,
as long as this quantity
never gets smaller than log n,
then this thing will be
log log n, and it's fine.
But in particular,
if this is constant,
then it's only achieving
log log n, so it's not--
there's an additive log
log n per operation loss.
That's the best binary
search, unified binary search
tree known.
OK, so this is all good.
And this is sort of where the,
what we call analytic bounds,
here ends.
There are various attempts to--
in general we want
to characterize,
what is the optimal
thing we could hope for.
When can we do
better than log n?
These are all
specific cases where
we can do better than
log n, but it's not
a complete characterization.
There are sequences that
have large unified bound,
but have no--
yet they can be
accessed more quickly
by the optimal
binary search tree.
And so, while it would
be nice to characterize
with some clean algebraic,
whatever, most of the work,
beyond what I've
told you about here,
is just trying to
figure out what opt is.
Instead of trying to write
it down, try to compute it.
Instead of trying
to define something
that happens to
match the optimal,
let's just go for optimal.
And this is the notion
of dynamic optimality.
And in modern
terminology this would
be called constant
competitive, but the paper then
introduced dynamic optimality
preceded competitive analysis,
so it has another name.
What we'd like, is that
the total cost of all
your accesses, so this
is like amortized cost,
is within a constant
factor of the optimal.
What's the optimal?
This is the-- over all
binary search trees,
I mean to be precise I should
talk about binary search tree
algorithms, meaning you specify
somehow how to do a search,
and it may involve
rotations and walks.
So, you know, it could
be red black tree,
it could be an AVL tree,
could be a [? BB ?] alpha
tree, anything that can be
implemented in this way.
Those are all kind of boring.
More sophisticated is
something like a splay tree.
Ideally, you take
the min over all--
min over all binary
search tree algorithms.
The cost of that algorithm, on
that access sequence x, and you
want the total cost
of your algorithm
on x to be within a constant
factor of the optimal algorithm
on x.
x is a vector.
So this is what you call
the offline optimal,
because here you basically get
to choose the binary search
tree algorithm to
be customized to x,
and yet somehow you want to
achieve dynamic optimality.
Open question, is this possible?
And, of course, we're only
interested in online solutions.
So, you want to build a
binary search tree that
doesn't know the
future, it doesn't
know what accesses
are to come, but it
has to be within a constant
factor of the offline solution
that does know.
And we don't know
whether this is possible.
Another interesting
question, is whether it's
possible for a pointer
machine, because save
for the unified property
we know how to get it
for a pointer machine.
And there's two versions
of this question.
You can consider, is
there a pointer machine
that matches the optimal
binary search tree,
or you could ask, is there a
pointer machine that matches
the optimal pointer machine.
That's a little less defined,
although there are some--
I have some ideas on how to
define that problem, maybe will
work on it.
But all versions of this
problem are open, basically.
So, this may seem
rather depressing.
What else am I going to do
for a lecture and a half?
But actually, there's a lot
of study of this problem,
and we do know some good things.
For example, we can get
log log n competitive.
So, not within a
constant factor,
but we can get within a log
log n factor of the optimal.
So, that's pretty good.
An easy result is to
get log n competitive.
Any balanced binary
search tree is log n
competitive, because best case
you could hope for is constant,
the worst case you
can hope for is log n.
So at least within
the log factor,
but we can do
exponentially better.
We'll do that next class.
Before we go there, I want to
tell you about two structures,
to binary search trees that
we conjecture are dynamically
optimal, but we can't prove it.
So first one, and the classic
one, is splayed trees.
I don't want to spend too
much time on splay trees,
but just to let you know what
they are if you don't already
know.
If you want to search
for x, you search for x.
You do a binary search
for x in the tree.
You locate x, and then you--
splay trees always
move x to the root.
So, this is what we call
a self-adjusting tree.
It changes the structure of
the tree as you do searches,
not just when you're
doing updates,
and there are two cases.
If you look at x, and its
parent and its grandparent,
if they're oriented
the same way.
So, here it's two left pointers,
could be two right pointers.
Then you flip them.
So we rotate y, and then rotate
x, so it's in this model.
And we get x y z
in the other order.
There's pretty much
only one way to move
x to the root in that picture.
Then the other case is
the zigzag case, y, w, x.
So, here the two parent pointers
are in different directions,
one is left, one is right.
There's a symmetric picture.
In this case, we rotate
in the other order.
So, we rotate x, and
then we rotate y.
And in that case you get x
nice, x, w, y, and the subtrees
hang off.
I'm not labeling the
subtrees, but they
have to be labeled in the
same order, left to right.
OK, this is splay trees.
You do this for x. x is
the thing you search for,
now x is up here,
then you repeat.
You look at it's two parents,
it's one of these two cases,
you do the appropriate
two rotations.
Until x is either the
root, and you're done,
or it's one child from
the root, and then
you do one rotation
to make it the root.
Seems simple enough.
It's slightly more sophisticated
than an algorithm known as move
to root, which is just
rotate x, rotate x,
rotate x, which would
eventually propagate it up.
Move to root is a
really bad algorithm.
It can show its can be a
factor of square root of n.
It can be square root of n per
operation if you're unlucky.
Splay trees are always, at most
log n amortized per operation,
although that's
not at all obvious.
Rough intuition, is if you
look at the path, the route
to x path, half of the nodes,
at most half of the nodes
go down when you splay.
So why is that?
Here, see y stays
at the same level.
z goes down, but x goes up.
Here, w stays at the same level,
x goes up, y goes down by one,
x goes up by two, so you might
call that a net improvement.
But in general you don't
mess up the path too much.
Half the items stay
where they are,
and so it's something
like your bisecting--
if you repeatedly
search for x, well
I'm not really searching
for x, but if you repeatedly
search for things
in that path, you're
kind of cutting the path
and half repeatedly.
It'll look kind of logarithmic,
that's a very vague argument.
And in the advanced
algorithms, it's
proved why this is
log n amortized.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Rotate x, rotate
x, I think you're right.
Yeah, y would go
somewhere else, thanks.
Yeah, so here it looks like
move to root, here it doesn't.
Good, and there's lots of
things known about splay trees.
So for example, they satisfy
the sequential access property.
There's an entire paper,
combinatoric on 1985 Tarjan
I believe, proving splay trees
have the sequential access
property.
Not at all obvious,
but it's true.
They have the
working set property,
and therefore they have
the entropy property.
That's in the original
splay tree paper.
It's not that hard to prove.
Once you prove log n, with
a little bit more effort
you can prove the
working set property.
We won't do it here.
It's a cool amortization.
Splay trees also have the
dynamic finger property.
This is a series of two
papers, over 100 pages long.
Very difficult to prove.
In general, splay trees
are hard to work with,
because it's hard to keep
track of what's going on.
You can define
potential functions,
and that will prove this,
and with a lot of effort
it will prove this.
We don't know whether
splay trees satisfy
the unified property,
and more to the point,
we don't know whether splay
trees are dynamically optimal.
This is the big question, and
in the original splay tree paper
it asked this question,
are splay trees
dynamically optimal.
Still open, I wish I knew
the answer, but we don't.
So what the rest of today's
lecture is going to be about
is a geometric view, which
I've kind of been hinting
at with this picture, but
it's, there's more to it
than just plot the
points of searches.
There's a way, not only to
see what the searches are,
but to see what the binary
search tree algorithm is.
So, at this point binary
search tree algorithms
are kind of abstract.
I mean, we've kind
of drawn pictures,
and how to do
specific cases, you
know how red black
trees or something work.
But, you know, it's
complicated to write down
one of these algorithms.
How would we think
about all of them?
What would you think
about the optimal one?
Turns out there's a geometric
view, in which it's actually
very easy to see what
the algorithm is,
but it takes a
little bit of work
to prove that it's
the right thing.
And it suggests a totally
obvious offline optimal
algorithm, which we
don't know is optimal,
but we think is offline optimal.
It's like the obvious thing
to do, which we'll get to,
and we can actually
make it online.
So, this is-- this
gives us a binary search
tree that is so
obviously optimal,
where splay trees is kind
of vaguely feels good,
this is really obvious,
yet we can't prove it.
So it's like we're one step
closer, but not quite there.
So that's where we're going.
So this geometric view was
the topic of [? Deion ?]
[? Harmon's ?] PhD
thesis, here at MIT.
And it's also with John Iacono,
[? Danielle ?] [? Caine, ?] who
was an undergrad here, and
[? Mihal ?] [? Piotrowski, ?]
who was an undergrad
and a PhD here.
It was published
three years ago, 2009.
So, here's the idea.
Access sequence, this is the
sequence of searches you do.
That's very easy, you just
map it to the set of points
where, I guess I'm going
to switch things on you.
Sorry about that.
X-axis is going to be space,
y-axis is going to be time.
And I'm going to look at a
specific example of this.
Sort of pinwheel.
Four accesses at--
the first time
we access key three, then
we access key one, then
key four, then key two.
We've been drawing this
picture throughout the lecture.
Now the interesting part, is
if you look at a binary search
tree that actually
accesses these elements,
here's the exciting part.
We're going to map this
to a point set, which
is which nodes get
touched during a search,
during each search.
OK, this is the fun part.
So, what does touched mean?
I erased the model, but in
general with a binary search
tree, we only have one
pointer into the tree.
It starts at the root, it
can go left, it can go right,
it can go to the parent.
Every node that gets
visited during-- it
can do rotations,
every node that
gets visited by walking, that's
what I call a touched node.
Just look at all of them.
So for example,
in this picture--
color-- suppose,
maybe we're lucky,
and key three is at the root.
So that's the only
thing I touch.
If that's the case,
when I access one,
it's definitely not the root.
So, in particular, I definitely
have to have touched that node.
And I'm just going to fill
in a reasonable choice.
I happen to know, this is
a valid binary search tree.
Not so obvious, but
you can find one.
I'm using here, the
greedy algorithm actually,
I'm cheating.
We'll get to what that is.
But in general, some point
sets, like this point set,
are not valid.
There's no binary search tree
that has this touch pattern.
You just can't jump
around, teleport,
without getting somewhere.
But, this one is valid.
So, which ones are valid?
Oh sorry I need one more point.
Which ones are valid,
which ones are invalid?
How did I know that
that was invalid,
and now this one is valid?
Well, there's a
theorem tell you.
Then what I was just doing
there will become clear.
So, I want to know when is
the point set a valid BST
execution, and I claim
it is, if and only
if, in every rectangle
spanned by two points
not on a common horizontal
or vertical line,
in every rectangle, there
there's another point.
So, let me draw a picture.
I have some point set.
We'll look at this
one in a moment.
In general, I take
any two points
that are not horizontally
or vertically aligned,
that spans a rectangle.
In other words, the
rectangle with those two
as opposite corners.
There's got to be another
point in there, somewhere.
Could be on the boundary,
could be interior.
OK, in fact, you can
pump this a little bit.
So once I find some point,
let's say on the interior,
then my picture looks like this.
Maybe I'll just
draw it as a circle.
Well, here's another rectangle.
That one has to have
a point inside it.
Here's another
rectangle, that one
has to have a point inside it.
You could keep going, until you
know maybe I'd put one here,
maybe I put one here.
OK if I update the
picture then, I still
have a little
rectangle like that,
little rectangle like that,
little rectangle like this.
At this point, this point
is no longer involved
in any rectangles
essentially, because there's
no rectangle between
these two points
because they're
horizontally aligned.
I could finish this off,
finally, by adding points,
let's say at the corners.
Once I add points at the
corners this will be satisfied.
We call this property
arborally satisfied.
Gotta look up the spelling.
Arboral satisfaction.
Arboral means having
to do with a tree.
OK, so this is saying that
point set is treelike,
if it has this property.
OK this picture is
getting a little messy,
but if I have any monotone path,
like this, this is satisfied.
If you look at any rectangle,
say this one, it has points--
other points in it.
OK, if I look at, I
don't know, this one,
it has another point in it.
But look at this one, that one
doesn't count because it's just
a vertical line.
So it has to have non-zero area.
If you look at any two
points, this one and this one,
they span a rectangle, there's
another point in there.
So, monotone paths are good.
This point set.
If I drew it correctly, is good.
I look at any rectangle here,
it's got another point in it.
Takes some practice to be able
to see all the rectangles,
but check it.
Eventually this one is good.
This one's obviously bad.
It has lots of wrecked-- we
call these empty rectangles,
unsatisfied rectangles, that
have no extra points in them.
So, this is a valid BST
execution, this is not.
Let's prove this theorem
it's actually not that hard.
The consequence
of the theorem, is
it tells us what we need to do.
We are given a
point set like this,
we want a point set like this.
We can define the cost
of a binary search tree
to be how many
nodes does it touch.
That's within a constant factor
of how many operations you do.
If you don't want to,
it's pointless to touch
a node more than a
constant number of times.
You can prove that.
So, really we just care about
how many nodes get touched.
So, what we want to do is find
a minimum superset of this point
set that is satisfied.
We're given a set to
represent or access
sequence that is not satisfied.
We need to act-- we need
to touch those points.
That's the definition of search.
And now we'd just like to also
touch some other points that
make it satisfied.
This is a geometric
interpretation of dynamic opt.
Can you find the
offline optimal, is--
what's the minimum
number of points
to add in order to make your
point set arborally satisfied.
We don't know whether
that problem is NP hard.
Probably it is.
We don't know how to compute it.
We don't know how to
find a constant factor
approximation, unfortunately.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So, this is for and
access sequence, so every time
corresponds to just
seeking like one
individually thing in the tree?
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: OK, that
makes more sense.
PROFESSOR: Yes, so the input--
there is a unique
thing, a key, that
gets accessed at each time.
So if you draw any horizontal
line, in the input point
set there's only one point
in each horizontal line.
There can be multiple points
in each vertical line, which
would mean that key gets
accessed more than one time.
That's the obvious
interpretation terms
of binary search tree, turns
out you don't need to assume
either of those things.
You could allow a
sort of multi-search,
where I say during this round
you have to access key 5 and 7,
I don't care in what order.
Whereas normally I say,
you have access key 5,
then you have to access key 7.
You could do a
multi-search, where
there's multiple
points in a single row.
All of the things I'll say
work, it doesn't really
make a difference as the claim.
You could also assume that no
key is accessed more than once,
so then there's only one--
those would be the
opposite extreme.
You can assume there's
only one key per column.
That turns out not to
make much difference.
If there's multiple keys
in the same position,
just spread them out
a little and you'll
get roughly the same cost.
So, good question.
But in the natural
interpretation
there's one per row,
multiple per column,
but it doesn't,
neither one matters.
OK.
So this becomes the problem,
go from this to this,
with a minimum number
of added points.
We do know a log log n
approximation to that problem.
That's the best we know.
You just take this
binary search tree,
and apply this transformation,
and it tells you
if you have a
binary search tree,
you can turn it into a way
to satisfy a point set.
But this is actually the
best approximation algorithm
that we know.
But as you'll see, the geometric
view offers a lot of insight.
Gives us a lot of
power, and in some sense
we use it to construct this.
OK, so let's prove the theorem.
So there's two directions.
We'll start with
the easy direction.
If you have a
binary search tree,
then it must be
arborally satisfied.
Then we'll have
to do the reverse,
actually build a binary search
tree out of a point set.
That's kind of the harder step.
So, let's say we
have two points.
Let's say this is that
time i, we access key x,
and this one is at time
j, we access key y.
Let's suppose y
is greater than x,
there's the symmetric picture.
We want to argue that
there is some other point
in this rectangle.
OK, here's the plan, let a be
the lowest common ancestor of x
and y.
x is a key, y is a key,
they are nodes in the tree.
This is a changing quantity.
As the tree wiggles
around those rotations,
the least common
ancestor changes.
But at every time,
there is, it has
some of these common ancestor.
Might be x, might be y,
might be some other node.
OK?
I want to look at
a couple of things.
Let's say, right before
x is touched at time i,
or I guess right before time i
would be the proper phrasing.
So we're at this moment, I
want to know does a equal x?
If a does not equal
x, then I'm going
to use the point a comma i.
OK?
Least common ancestor has the
property that x is less than
or equal to a, is less
than or equal to y.
Common ancestor,
least common ancestor
will be between x and y.
And we also know that
it's an ancestor of x,
and it's an ancestor of y.
So, if you're going to
touch x, you must touch a.
If you're going to touch
y, you must touch a.
So a comma i is going to
be some point here, which
is what we need.
Except, if a equals x, sorry,
what the heck did I do?
Transposed again.
OK, this is time i, time
j, x, y, sorry about that.
OK, here's time i, here is a.
So, if a does not equal
x, we know at time i,
we must access
all ancestor of x,
we must touch all ancestors
of x, before we touch x.
Therefore, this is
a point and we're
done, unless a equals
x at this time,
because then it's
the same point.
We didn't get a third
point, we at least
need to find some different
point other than these two.
OK, so that would be good.
We can-- so it must actually be
that at this time, at time i,
a is right here.
Let's then look at time j.
Same deal, at time j,
here's y that gets access.
We must also access a.
Now it could be its equal to y,
or it could be somewhere else.
It could be here, or
could be still here.
In those cases we're
happy, but this one also
could have been at the corner.
The case we're not happy is when
b equals x, sorry, a equals y.
Getting my letters mixed up.
As long as a does
not equal y, then
we can use the point a
comma j, that must be,
these are always
in your execution,
and if a does not equal y, then
we're, that's a third point
and we're done.
So we're left with one more
case, which is that at time i,
a is here, here's a, and
at time j, a is here.
Question is, what
happened in between?
a changed.
For a to change, something
in here has to get rotated.
That's the [? clam. ?] I mean
here's the picture, you have a,
actually-- picture is
at the beginning a is x.
So, here we have x, and then
y is an ancestor, sorry,
y is a descendant of
x, because this is a.
And then somehow we
have to transition
to the reverse picture,
which is that y is
the least common ancestor, x.
And for this to happen, somebody
here has to get rotated.
I guess, in particular x.
At some point x had to
overtake y, had to be moved up.
So, at some point x was
rotated, and that would
correspond to a point here.
So else x must be
rotated at some time
k, where k is between i and j.
And if we set it up right, I
guess because here a was still
x, and here a is y, then it
must be strictly between.
Maybe like this would
be what we want.
And so then we use
the point k comma x.
Is that more or less clear?
This was the easy case.
I guess it depends
what you consider easy.
Here we're just, we're
given a search tree
and the short version is, look
at the least common ancestor.
It's got to move around at
some point, or not, either way
you're happy.
So the least common
ancestor gives you
the points you care about.
So for that we just needed the
least common ancestor idea.
For the other
direction, if we're
given a point set
that corresponds
to, that has this
satisfaction property,
we have to somehow build from
scratch a binary search tree.
How the heck are we going to
build a binary search tree?
Well, with treaps.
So, this is the other direction.
Treap is a portmanteau
of tree and heap.
Underline it
correctly, tree, heap.
So, it's simultaneously a binary
search tree and a min heap,
in this case.
It's a binary search tree
because it has to be.
It's a binary search
tree on the keys.
It's going to be heap on
a different set of values.
So, binary search tree on
the keys, and it's heap
ordered, min heap
ordered, by next access.
I didn't say I was going to
give you an online algorithm,
this is an offline algorithm.
So it looks-- if
I look at a key,
and it's going to be accessed
next, it better be at the root.
Next access will
always be at the root,
if you're heap ordered.
If you're a min
heap by next access.
This is great, that
means the thing you're
searching for is
always at the root,
and it's basically
free to touch.
But you may choose
to touch other nodes.
And in fact, we're told
how to touch notes.
We're given a pattern
that says, well,
at this time you have-- you
will touch this node, this node,
and this node.
By that definition, this
one will be at the root,
but you're going to
touch these nodes,
and possibly you
could rotate them.
Change the tree.
You'll have to, actually,
because next access
time is constantly changing.
And as soon as you
access an item,
it's next access goes in
sometime in the future,
possibly infinity, and so you'd
like to start pushing it down
in the tree.
So, what we need to
do is show that we
can maintain-- it's always going
to be a binary search tree,
because we only do rotations.
We have to somehow use rotations
to maintain this heap order
property, and only touch
the nodes that we're
supposed to touch.
That's the challenge.
So, I should mention, this is
not a uniquely defined tree.
Usually treaps are unique,
if you specify a key order,
and you specify a
heap order, there
is exactly one tree that
satisfies both of them.
But here it's not quite
unique, because the next access
time-- there are many keys that
are going, sorry, next touch.
Next touch time.
So, for example, at this
moment all three of these nodes
are going to be accessed
at the same time.
And so you don't
know, or I'm not
specifying how they're supposed
to be heap ordered in the tree.
Just break ties arbitrarily,
it doesn't matter.
OK.
So, let's look at a time i.
When we reach that
time i, the nodes
to touch form and connected
subtree containing the root.
Because according to
heap order, they're all,
they all want to be at the root.
So we break ties arbitrarily,
somehow, you know all the nodes
that we're supposed to touch,
live in some connected subtree
of the root.
Sorry, some connected
subtree containing the root.
Everything down here has
a later next touch time,
and so they're below, by
definition of heap order.
OK, now one of these is the
one we actually want to access.
But we need to touch all of
them, so touch all of them,
you know, navigate.
Walk left, right, whatever.
The big question is, what
should we change this tree into?
I'd like to change it to
some other top structure.
I can't touch
anything down here,
I'm only allowed to
touch these points.
I only want to
rotate these somehow.
There's a convenient
theorem, if you have one tree
and you want to convert
it into another,
you can always do it in a
linear number of rotations.
So, rotations are basically
free and this model,
it's just about how
many nodes we touch.
We're told which nodes to touch.
We want to somehow rearrange
them to restore this heap order
property.
Right?
As soon as we touch
all these nodes,
their next touch time will
be sometime in the future.
We need to rearrange the
tree to still be heap ordered
by that new next touch time.
OK, here's what we do.
I mean there's only
one thing to do.
Rearrange those nodes in
this connected subtree
to be a local treap by
the new next touch time.
These are the only nodes to
get a new next touch time,
so it's more or less unique
how to rearrange them.
Do that.
Now the hard part is to argue
that the whole thing is now
a treap.
Why was it enough to
only modify these nodes?
Maybe you set one of these nodes
to have a very large next touch
time, so it's got to be
really deep down there.
And you can't afford to push it
down deep, because you're not
allowed to touch
any of these nodes.
Looks worrisome, but
turns out, it just works.
So, if there were a failure,
picture would be like this.
We rearrange these nodes
perfectly, in particular,
let's look at some
node x that has a child
y, that was not touched.
So x was touched, all of
it's ancestors were touched,
but y was not touched.
So we know that the
next touch time of x
is greater than or equal to the
next touch time of its parent,
of it's ancestor,
up to the root.
The worry would be that
the next touch time of x
is greater than the
next touch time of y.
So suppose next touch of x is
greater than next touch of y.
This would be a problem, because
then you would not be a heap.
So, claim is we get an
unsatisfied rectangle
based on x and it's next touch
time, and y and it's next touch
time.
So let's draw the picture.
Here's time, here's
space, I'm going
to assume by symmetry x
is to the left of y and
[? keyspace, ?] and
now we're supposing
the next touch time of y is
earlier than the next touch
time of x.
So it looks like this.
So this is next touch time of
x, this is the next time of y,
and I claim that there are
no other points in here.
That would be a contradiction,
because we assume
that the thing is satisfied.
To prove this, I need to go back
a little bit to the definition,
over here.
There are actually a
couple of different ways
to think about satisfaction,
which I was getting at here,
but I didn't solidify.
So, I said OK, if
you have two points
and that rectangle
is satisfied, there
is some point, possibly in the
interior, in that rectangle.
But if it's interior,
then I can keep going.
If I keep going, in the end I
can conclude that not only is
this rectangle
non-empty, but there
has to be a point on
one of these two sides,
because if I choose
any other point,
I get a smaller rectangle.
Eventually, I have to get one
on one of those two sides.
Could be at the
corner, or this corner,
but one of those two sides
has to have a point on it.
Also, one of these two sides
It could be both of
these constraints
are met at once by having
one point in the corner.
Well that's a somewhat stronger
formulation, but equivalent
formulation of the
satisfaction property.
So in particular over
here, it should be the case
that there's a point,
either here or here,
and there should be a
point, either here or here.
I claim that one of
those is violated.
You think I'd know this stuff,
I wrote the paper, but--
it's all these subtle
details, easy to get wrong.
I think what I want
to look at is, now,
which is the moment we're
drawing this diagram, versus
the next time of y.
Sorry, so this is x comma now.
That's what my diagram
looks like there,
so I think that's what I mean.
So ignore this picture.
What we learn, what we know
is the next access to x,
is sometime in the future.
That's what we're told here.
Next touch of x is greater
than next touch of y.
So next touch of x is up here,
which means this is empty.
OK, if that's empty,
this better not be empty.
All right that's what we
claim, one of these two
has to have a point in it.
This one's empty, so
this better not be empty,
but I claim this is empty.
Suppose it's not, suppose it
is, suppose it's not empty--
Wait, no, one of these.
Suppose it's not empty, should
be the correct scenario.
Look at the left most
point in this range.
This guy.
It's a point between x and
y, in terms of key value.
So, in this picture,
where could it be?
Where are the points between
x and y in this diagram?
They have to be in
the left subtree of y.
Right?
The only points in a binary
search-- if x and y are--
if y is a child of x, the
only points in the binary tree
that are between x and y,
or the left subtree of y,
or there's a symmetric case,
but in this picture left subtree
of y.
But I put an x here.
That means that whoever
we're looking at,
some point between x and y,
has to be in this top tree.
Contradiction, done, OK?
If this guy is in there,
then y was also in there,
which meant there
was a point here,
and that's what we're
assuming did not happen.
This is supposed
to be an interface
between inside the
set of touched nodes,
and outside the set
of touched nodes.
So there can't be
any points in here,
which means this is empty, which
means you weren't satisfied.
OK, maybe I should
write down the words
to go with that argument, but--
So, this part is empty by
next touch of x being greater
than next touch of y.
And this part is empty
else, or it's empty
because any key
between x and y is
in the left subtree of
y, which would imply
if it's touched then so is y.
But y cannot be
touched, by assumption.
So that's the end of that proof.
A little bit longer,
but hopefully
it's pretty clear at this point.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Can't
there be something
like a descendent of x,
but an ancestor of y,
instead of being in
a subtree with y?
PROFESSOR: Would,
so you could say
it could be in between here.
It could be a descendant
of x, but an ancestor of y,
but we're assuming here that
this was a child relation.
y was a child of x.
This was a--
I didn't say that
at the beginning.
On a claim that's a
global treap, if it's not
a global treap, there is
some edge that's violated,
that does not have
heap order property.
So assuming this was
an edge, x is OK,
it was in the local
treap, y somehow
is going to be bad, because
it's next touch time was,
should be higher.
Should be above.
Other question?
AUDIENCE: So that
[INAUDIBLE] you drew,
and all the everything in that
subtree root that gets taken
to--
Like the picture on
the right is also,
it's the same subtree right?
But after you change
their [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: These two subtrees
have the same set of nodes,
they've just been
rotated somehow.
AUDIENCE: OK, but then
how do you-- but didn't
we change the next touch times
of all the nodes in there?
So how you do know if
the root is still going
to be some guy in that subtree?
PROFESSOR: Buy this argument.
So the question is
say, after we do this,
we make some root,
which is going,
the root is going to
be among all the nodes
that just got touched now, who
is going to be touched next?
That's who we put at the root.
And the claim is, that
is globally the node that
will be touched next.
Why?
By this argument.
If there were some other node
down here that has a smaller
next access time, then--
but we know that it was
heap ordered before,
so all of these guys
are heap ordered.
So, this guy would
then have the minimum.
And then we look
at that interface,
and the claim is by the
satisfaction property,
actually this point should
have been in the set.
So, what this tells
you is the guy that
has to be accessed
next, in particular,
must be in your set.
Must be touched now.
Kind of magical.
Well actually, it's because
they're tie-breaking
I think, that this works out.
Anyway, another question?
AUDIENCE: So, like when you're
rearranging the [INAUDIBLE]
in the sort of subtree
on top [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we're
doing this transformation
of the top tree into the
local tree by rotations.
I mentioned--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
It's always--
PROFESSOR: Right,
so we're staying
within the binary search tree
model, and in particular then
we stay a binary search tree.
So, we can't mess things up.
And there's a nice theorem that
if you have two binary search
trees on the same,
keys there's a way
to get there with the
linear number of rotates,
so that's for free.
So, our new cost model
is just to count points.
The cost of this access is
one, the cost of this access
is two, two, three.
If we just count how
many nodes are touched,
then the cost of the
binary search tree
is equal to the cost of
the minimum satisfied
superset of your point.
So this is the problem now.
Sadly we don't know how
to solve the problem.
We do know some things.
I don't think I'll go
through an example of this,
it's not very exciting.
You could run
through this picture,
and see how the binary
[? structure ?] changes.
Actually the binary
[? structure ?]
won't change it all here, so
it's a little anticlimactic
of an example.
You can see it in the notes.
I want to get to the greedy
algorithm, so let's go here.
Last bullet.
The idea is to imagine
your points are added one
at a time, bottom up.
So I'm going to do
the same example.
First we add this point.
That's a satisfied set, done.
In general add necessary points
on the same row as the search.
OK, there's nothing to add here.
Next point we add is over here.
I've got the orientation
correct, yeah.
So this was three, this was one.
Is this satisfied?
No, there's a bad
rectangle here.
There's two obvious ways
to satisfy the rectangle,
I could add a point here,
or I could add a point here.
I'm going to add a point
here, because that's the row,
this is current time.
OK, it's like a
sweep line algorithm.
We go up, next
point is over here.
That's the Next
position to sweep line.
Now there's a bad rectangle.
We fix it by adding this point.
Now we're good, all
rectangles are satisfied.
Next level is,
there's a point here.
Now there's two bad rectangles.
This one, I'm going
to add a point here,
and this one, I'm going
to add a point here.
Now we're good.
And that should be
what I did here.
Yeah.
So that's how I
found that point set,
and in general claim is
this is a good algorithm.
It seems, in fact,
pretty obvious.
There was a choice of
course, we could satisfy
this corner or this corner.
Or some monotone
path in between.
But the claim would be that--
doesn't make that
big a difference.
Doing things later
is always better.
It's kind of a lazy property.
Or you could think of this--
Originally actually
this algorithm
goes back in tree land.
And in tree land, if you follow
through this reduction, which
we did, you know
if you convert this
into a treap, what
this is saying is,
look you search for an
item, you follow a path.
Take all the nodes on
the path that you follow,
rearrange them optimally
for the future,
build a heap based on the next
access time, next touch time,
whenever that happens to be.
Next access time
actually, in that case.
That is equivalent
to this algorithm.
That seems like the right
thing to do offline.
You visit your item, you do the
minimum amount you have to do,
which is following
the search path.
You rearrange those items to
be optimal for the future.
It's an offline algorithm,
seems like a really good one.
The only thing
it's missing out on
is maybe you should
go off the path
and bring other guys
closer to the root.
But if you believe, which
we don't know how to prove,
if you believe that there's no--
it doesn't really
buy you anything
to go off the path now,
you can always do it later,
then this algorithm
is optimal offline.
And in terms of the
point set it's--
in the point set of
view it's kind of nice
because it almost
looks online, right.
You only have to
look at each time
and add the points at
that time that are useful,
in terms of the past.
You only had to satisfy
the rectangles of the past.
So this is where
things get interesting,
because in terms of a tree
view, with this transformation,
this looks like an
offline tree because it
needs to know the future.
And it does if you
want to build a heap.
OK, but if you look
at in the geometric
view, suddenly it looks
online, because you're only
looking at the points
and all the points
you've accessed in the past.
So, in fact, there's a
way to make this online.
This is where things
get interesting.
There is a transformation
that if you
have an online satisfying
point set, meaning you
can decide what points to
add based only on the past,
not on the future.
So it's a fancier version
of this transformation,
you get an actual online
binary search tree.
So, this algorithm goes
back to the '90s I think.
Actually '88, it's in a
thesis 1988 as rediscovered
by my PhD adviser in 2000.
It's totally natural
algorithm, but they thought
it was an offline algorithm.
With this view, it's
an online algorithm.
Let me quickly convince
you, or sketch to you,
how we make this online.
So we do the same thing, except
we don't know how to heapify,
because we don't know
the next access times.
But we know whatever
we touch, it's
some connected
subtree of the root.
We know what we touch.
We touch whatever greedy
tells us to touch.
We'll touch all
these guys, whatever.
How do we rearrange them?
We don't rearrange them.
We store them into something
called a split tree.
Split tree has the
feature, it's a tree.
Binary search tree, and if
you ask for some item x,
you can move x to the root.
So then you have a
left subtree of x,
right subtree of x,
and then delete x,
and now you're left with
things that are less than x,
and things that
are greater than x.
Things are greater than x.
And you can do all this
in constant amortize time.
This is what we need,
if you think about here.
I'm going to take all these
items that were touched,
throw them into a split tree.
My resulting structure will
be a tree of split trees.
So think of it as, when
I touch all these items
I just sort of throw
them all in the root,
but that root is
represented by a split tree.
And then hanging off here, there
are other split trees which
may have several keys in them.
When I do, when I
now touch a node,
you can show that if I'm
trying to touch some node here,
I can't just magically
touch a node here.
I've got to, I had
to have followed
in the actual tree, whatever
the optimal tree is,
I had to follow some
route to leave path.
So in fact, the
predecessor and successor
here had to have been touched
before I touched this one.
Which means I'm going
to split those nodes.
So, when I actually-- this
is basically lazy evaluation.
When I actually access
something in here,
that means I want to
pull it to the root.
I wanted to pretend that
it was at the root, that's
what the treap would have done.
So basically pull it
up, be a root, split,
because now there's
two structures left
where I don't know
their orders, but I
know that this item was first.
And so I end up with--
I don't actually remove
it, but I remove it
from the split trees, so
I make it look like this.
And here's the guy where I
wanted to access something.
So, I split this root
into two split trees,
and I have an
individual node up here.
If I can do this in
constant amortize time,
it's as if this node was at
the root in the first place.
And so I simulate this
perfect treap order,
but using a data
structure, split trees,
which can actually be solved.
How do you solve split trees?
You just do the obvious
thing, more or less.
Ideas, you know red
black trees, take
your favorite balanced
binary search tree,
red black trees work fine.
If you're given a node,
you can split there.
You basically just
carve it in half.
How much does it cost to split?
Well if you're a
little bit clever,
let me go to a
board of cleverness.
The one thing we
have to optimize for
is, what if you're
splitting like right
here, very close to the left?
If you're clever,
you'll search from here,
and cut off this part in
time basically proportional
to the height of that tree.
OK, you might get some
propagation up here,
but that's very small amortized.
OK, on the other hand,
if you search over here,
you'd like to spend only
time proportional to this.
So in general, if you just
search in parallel here,
you can split in--
let's say this has size n one,
and the rest has size n two.
You can split in order log
the min of n one and n two.
And you can show that if you
just-- that's straightforward
splitting, that's
really easy to do.
You can show that that
implies constant amortized,
because either you're cutting
off a very little nibble
and the cost is small,
or you're cutting things
more or less in half, but
that can't happen very much.
Then you charge to the fact
that log n is going down by one,
and overall you get a linear
cost to splitting nodes.
It's an amortization.
Now the trouble is this is
not a binary search tree.
How in the heck do
I have to pointers
that in parallel search?
Well you have to take these
two halves of the tree
and interleave them to make
them a binary search tree.
It's kind of awkward, but just
put it, mash it all together.
Fold it in half, basically
and turn it upside down,
and you've got a
binary search tree.
So there's some
messy stuff there,
but that's just a
hand-wavy argument
that you can make greedy online.
Next class we'll talk about
lower bounds, which almost
proved the greedy is optimal.
But not quite.